Cobalt is element number 27,
between iron 26 and nickel 28.
And like most elements. It's really quite interesting. It is a catalyst.
It can be used in magnets.
It is important in the batteries that we have in all our modern electronic
equipment and above all it is associated with the color blue,
the element where it's compounds has been known for a long time,
because it's been used for coloring glass.
I've found in my cupboard at home,
quite a nice glass jar,
which everybody has told me is a 19th century Christmas tree
light with a candle in it though.
I'm sure some viewers will tell me it's something more boring,
but I still think it's a Christmas tree light and you can see it has got this
glorious blue color. Did you buy it in the 19th century?
Um, I can't remember when I bought it, but it was a long time ago.
They add a small amount of cobalt into the melt when they're making the
glass. And so you get isolated irons of cobalt,
which have this nice blue color cobalt itself is a shiny
metal. If it's polished and it's relatively dense,
it's quite heavy to hold.
It's used principally in alloys with other metals.
It used to be used a lot making magnets there.
Now you can get more powerful magnets using rare earth
because cobalt is a so-called transition metal.
The irons of cobalt say cobalt two plus that's cobalt with two
electrons removed. It's usually not naked.
It will be coordinated by other compounds.
For example, if you make it using water,
you get six water molecules round the cobalt.
So here you can see cobalt in the middle with six water
molecules round it.
Now you might ask how can you form so many bonds?
And the answer is that the interaction is partly electrostatic,
the negative oxygen interacting with the positive
cobalt. If you heat cobalt, chloride,
which has beautiful red colored crystals to high temperature,
you can drive off the water and make a sort of purplish palette.
[Inaudible].
We found a lovely,
really old sample of anhydrous without water
cobalt chloride in a bottle that's still sealed up with its original
wrapping.
We felt we really didn't have the heart to destroy this historic sample to
destroy the wrapping. So you'll have to look at it through the glass.
We had another sample of anhydrous Cobell chloride,
where the bottle had split.
So air and water could get in and you can see it goes back to the pinkish color.
So we've got two demonstrations for you.
The first one is to demonstrate how in solution,
you can remove the water and substitute it with chloride diamonds by using
concentrated hydrochloric acid. We were so excited to do this,
that the first time we didn't do it very well.
We had to test tube of cobalt chloride solution.
You're nice to pinkish color and try dropping in concentrated hydrochloric
acid. But although you could see some changes of color,
the concentration of the acid was not.
So we reversed it and dropped the pink
solution into the colorless hydrochloric acid.
So now we had a whole test tube with hydrochloric acid and what we
saw,
and I hope you can is that as the pink solution goes in,
it goes bright blue.
And the bright blue is color is due to cobalt
irons with full chlorides irons.
So it goes to cobalt cl four to minus going
from cobalt to plus two minus science.
And the striking thing is of course, that it's a much darker color,
even though we're diluting it. If you drop the cobalt chloride into water,
you see almost no color because it's so dilute.
So the reason why you get this very intense color is because
of the change of the shape of the atoms immediately around the
cobalt, going from six, ran the cobalt to only four.
And this change of shape changes.
The quantum mechanical rules in which the electrons are
interact with light.
[Inaudible] in the second experiment.
I want you to see what happens if you drop cobalt chloride solution
into sodium hydroxide, quite concentrated,
and you would expect to see a precipitate of cobalt hydroxide,
which is pink. Now watch carefully as it comes in,
you get to precipitate a solid, but it's bright blue.
[Inaudible].
And then as you watch really quite slowly and
satisfyingly it's gradually goes pink to
make the product that you expect.
So this is an example of a reaction where the starting material
goes through some sort of intermediate compounds and then makes the product
and it makes the intermediate very quickly.
And then slowly it goes to the product.
And what's happening is that, first of all,
you get a mixed salt where you have both hydroxide and chloride,
which is still in soluble.
So it precipitates and then slowly,
and it's slow because it's in the solid state and has to read, dissolve.
The chloride is replaced by hydroxide to give you the pink color.
And it's really quite mesmerizing how these pink crystals,
rain down cobalt is also very important as a catalyst.
It is used in a variety of industrial processes,
particularly a process for converting natural gas or rather
a mixture of carbon monoxide and hydrogen,
which can be made from natural gas and has the rather amusing name of CIN
gas for synths gas and using a cobalt catalyst.
You can then convert it to liquid fuels for cars or lorries
and the advantages that you can take. Isolated gas fields, where there's,
um, natural gas, methane,
and converted into liquid fuel that can then be transported.
Cobalt is also very toxic.
We had some powdered cobalt so-called cobalt, sponge, and Neil.
Our technician was really quite nervous of this poisonous powder,
but cobalt is also vital for life.
It occurs in a molecule called vitamin B12,
which is present in living organisms and rather low concentration,
but catalyzes a whole series of important biological reactions and the
structure of vitamin B12 was determined by the British chemistry,
Dorothy Hodgkin,
who was the only woman who's won the Nobel prize for chemistry
from the UK.
So it is really a very historic structure.
This is Neil's new device. It's a very, very fancy erection. Essentially.
We've used a laboratory stand and we have an islet.
So this is just to act as a point where which we can raise up our
cesium on a piece of string.